BORIS: Welcome, everybody,
to one more Authors
at Google talk.
Today with us is Seth
Siegel, whose new book,
"Let There Be Water,"
has just been published.
Seth Siegel is a writer,
activist and serial
entrepreneur.
He's the author of the New
York Times best selling book,
"Let There Be Water,
Israel's Solution
for a Water-Starved World."
Siegel's essays on water
and other policy issues
have appeared in "The New
York Times," the "Wall Street
Journal," the "Los
Angeles Times,"
and the leading publications
in Europe and Asia.
Siegel is the co-founder
of several companies,
including Beanstalk, the
world's leading trademark brand
extension company.
He's a member of the Council
of Foreign Relations.
Siegel is married and
lives in New York City.
This book is a timely book for
us people living in California.
Obviously, there's been a
very dry couple of years.
But I wanted to say one
more thing about the book.
It may sound that it
applies only to water.
I went through the book,
and this book actually
applies to all sorts
of hard problems
that societies may face.
And so the techniques
and recipes
and methodologies that
are presented in the book
apply well beyond just
the problem of water.
With this, please welcome
Seth Siegel to Google.
SETH SIEGEL: Thank
you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Hi.
It's a pleasure to be here.
I would take a second to
tell you the story of how
I came to write this book.
Boris, in his kind
introduction, mentioned
that I'm a member of the
Council on Foreign Relations.
And about three
a half years ago,
I would happen to be
randomly at a session
there when I learned that
there was a coming global water
crisis.
And I thought to myself, I'm a
pretty well-informed citizen,
how come I'd never
heard that before?
And I thought it might
be that maybe there
was a gap in my
reading, or maybe it
was a gap in the media.
But whatever was, I was eager
to find out a little bit more.
I went back to my office.
And since I am here
at Google, I can
say I went onto Google,
my favorite search tool,
and started-- I won't use
the word inappropriately--
I started utilizing Google
to find what I could learn
about the coming water crisis.
And during this presentation
that I sat through,
the speaker was an
interesting fellow.
He was a retired
Air Force general
who now served in a leading
position in the National
Intelligence Council
in Washington, DC.
And he had just
completed a project,
which had been
classified and then
had just been
declassified, that came
to conclude that 60% of the
world's land mass and 40
of our 50 US states would,
by the year 2025-- which now
is only 10 years away--
would be experiencing
some degree of water scarcity.
Now, this was before anybody
was thinking about or talking
about the California drought.
So this was not sort
of uppermost in my mind
at the time.
What did occur to me, though,
is that if we have a problem
coming of such
extraordinary scale
as 60% of the world's land mass
is going to face water scarcity
and 80% of the United
States were going
to have water
scarcity issues, it
struck me as essential
that our policy
makers and concerned citizens
should know about that.
And I thought to
myself, if I don't
know about this, probably
lots and lots of other people
who I thought should know
about it don't know about it.
And so of the following
days and weeks,
I did a couple of things.
I continued utilizing Google as
a search vehicle for-- I love
this new terminology I'm
using, rather than "-ing"
at the end of that word.
I found myself
continuing to read more,
but I also found myself
asking well-informed friends
and some public
officials who I regard
as friends and colleagues.
I started asking them
to explain to what
degree they understood the
water problems that we had
that were coming, and
what they understood we
needed to do to get out of it.
And what I was not so
surprised to discover
was that the level of
awareness was practically
at the exact same
level as the level
that I had just a
few days earlier when
I heard the exact
same frightening news.
So here's what seems
so strange to me,
that when we have
a water main break,
and it leads the evening
news in our town,
we think about water for a
day, because maybe water gets
shut off.
Or when E. coli gets
into our water supply,
and we have to boil everything,
we think about our water.
Or when there's a pronounced
and prolonged drought,
we think about it.
But if, in fact, this guy's
presentation was so daunting--
and I'll get into,
in a moment, some
of the reasons why
he said we would
be facing these
problems-- and it
was going to be so prolonged,
why are we not doing more,
and why are we not asking of
our public officials to do more?
So what I learned
in the coming days,
after I began doing
some more research,
was that this is
a serious problem.
It's going to get worse.
It's going to get worse
widely, but that we're not
in a situation, necessarily,
where it will be
we're doomed for a "Mad Max,"
if you saw that movie, kind
of end of days, where
everything will be desert
and we'll all be
fighting over water.
And the reason why I
came to conclude this
is that there's a model for
somewhere in the world where
water actually is well
managed, and that is Israel.
So Israel is 60% desert.
It has about the world's
fastest-growing population.
It's grown tenfold in population
since independence in 1948.
It has among the world's
fastest-growing economies,
growing 70-fold also in
that same time period,
which is just remarkable.
Because generally
speaking, when you
look to see if a country's
going to have water problems,
you think of a couple
of different metrics.
One is population growth,
two is economic growth.
And in both of
those, Israel should
be in the red zone of problem.
The third area that
you might look at
is what is the natural amount
of rain or water that you have.
And Israel, because
of climate change,
had fallen in amount of
annual rainfall by about 50%
in the years since
1948 until present.
So you put all that
together, and you find out
that Israel has such
an abundance of water
that it finds itself
now able to export water
to its neighbors in the
West Bank, Palestinians
in the West Bank,
neighbors in Gaza,
and to the Kingdom of
Jordan on the other side
of the Jordan River.
So it seems almost
incomprehensible
that they are able to do that.
And then you learn
a little bit more,
you discover that they have
a robust multi-billion dollar
agricultural export industry.
Now, what is
agriculture, basically?
It's valuated water.
We don't think of it in those
terms, but that's what it is.
It's valuated water.
And only a country
that would be so
comfortable and confident that
its water future was secure
would think to build a large,
broad-based agricultural
industry that does more than
just feed their own people.
And yet, Israel had done that.
So I became curious as to
how and why that happened.
So I want to share
with you a little bit,
and given the interest
by the audience,
obviously, open
it up to questions
and have some
conversation as well.
So it starts quite
a long time ago.
What we know is that
not in every case,
but in many cases, what people
want, what people focus on,
is what people will achieve.
And so why has Israel
been a success in water,
where other parts of
the world have failed?
So let me start with a little
bit of historical perspective.
The founding prophet of Israel
was not David Ben-Gurion
or Chaim Weizmann, the
first President and Prime
Minister of the country, but
a man named Theodor Herzl.
Herzl was a largely assimilated
Jew living in Austria.
He was a novelist, a playwright,
an essayist, and a journalist.
And he got assigned to
cover the Dreyfus trial
in the late 1890s
in France, where
he learned of a French officer
who was railroaded, framed,
and sent off to a terrible
fate because he was Jewish,
a Jewish officer
in the French Army.
And this had a remarkable and
galvanizing effect on Herzl.
He had this epiphany,
this remarkable moment,
where the salvation of the
Jewish people, he said,
would be their own homeland.
And that's where the Zionist
idea, the political idea,
political Zionism begins.
Now what's remarkable
about that--
and I won't get back
to Herzl further,
but I just want to give you
some context for who he was
and how important he is in
the consciousness of Israelis
today.
Herzl writes-- as I
said, he was a novelist--
Herzl writes a series
of essays and novels
trying to describe
this new land that he
envisions some years hence.
And he writes a book
called "Altneuland."
And in this book, in the voice
of one of the main characters,
a protagonist, he has
him say that the heroes
of the new country will be
the water engineers, which
I found absolutely remarkable
when doing my research
and reading.
Why?
Because why would somebody
think, writing in 1902,
that the heroes of a country
that he couldn't even
imagine when it would be formed
would be the water engineers?
And I'll share
another small insight
with you as well about this.
And that is that
the other day, I
had reason to reread
the Nobel Prize
lecture given by Yitzhak Rabin.
Yitzhak Rabin had been
the highly decorated
Israeli soldier, he
had been the chief
of staff of the Israeli
Army during the Six-Day War.
And Rabin, after
his military career,
ends up going into politics,
and on several occasions,
was elected as Prime
Minister of the country.
He was a hero, much beloved,
and assassinated a few years
after winning the Nobel Peace
Prize, by a Jewish terrorist.
Rabin, in his Nobel
Prize lecture,
says, I did not mean
to become a soldier.
I did not need to carry a gun.
My plan, when I was a boy, was
to become a water engineer.
So once again, we find
that here are people,
from the earliest days
of the state to the more
contemporary days of
the state, thinking
to themselves about how water
plays a part in society.
And so the good news is that
water is not just water.
Water plays a large
role in the economy.
Water plays a role in
society, in the way
we organize
ourselves, in the way
we make options and choices of
what's most important and less
important in our society.
And in the case of
Israel, that exercise
has been ongoing from the
first days of the state
through today.
I'll tell you some of the
successes they've had,
but first I'd like to tack
back and tell you a bit more
about what I learned,
and why we're
going to a global water crisis.
So you shouldn't think that
I'm some alarmist who's
out you're just trying to
hawk a book about water.
So there are a handful of macro
reasons why we are on our way
to a problem, the first of
which, and most obvious,
is just simply the
numbers-- population.
We are globally, right now,
about 7 billion people.
The UN estimates are that we're
going to 9.6 billion people
over the next couple of decades.
So if we're already stressed
on our water supplies globally,
I'm not just speaking about
the US or California right now,
but if we're speaking about
our global water supplies,
and we're already
stretched-- and I'll
get into somewhat more so
some of the worst places where
we are most stretched where
they need it the most.
If we're already
stretched, how in the world
are we going to do
it, and provide water
for cleaning, for sanitation,
for health, for food,
for drinking?
How in the world are we going to
provide that when we're already
as stretched as we are?
And here's the other piece
of news about population.
We're not just growing larger,
we're growing more affluent.
And one of the surest indices of
affluence is water consumption.
And that's not because of
Jacuzzis in your backyard,
or because you take an
extra-long hot shower,
although that surely
adds to the equation.
The problem about
affluence is twofold.
One is diet, and
the other one is
the key part of your lifestyle.
To be middle class, some of
us may be vegan, some of us
may be vegetarians, but in
the main, people who are poor
don't have animal-based
diets, and in the main,
people who are affluent do.
Now, this has the larger
implications than just water.
But for example, to
take a pound of corn
and grow that versus
raising a pound of beef--
and plenty of people, either
you yourselves or people
who you know have beef
on a regular basis.
And probably very
few of you just
have some corn tacos as your
sustenance on a regular basis.
So a pound of corn versus a
pound of beef, a pound of beef
is 17 times more
water consumptive
than a pound of corn.
So once again, if a
billion new people
are going to come middle
class around the world,
that's a lot of cheeseburgers.
That's a lot of people
having a diet very
different than their
grandparents and parents had.
And that's going to consume
massive amounts of water that
currently have not
been identified.
Now the bogey, the
boogieman in all this
is clearly climate change.
We don't know how
extensive it's going
to be, we don't have
deep it's going to be,
but we know it's here.
And whether you are a believer
that climate change is
man-made or not man-made
that's irrelevant to me.
That's not part of this
conversation, that's
not part of the
debate, and I don't
need to get part
into that discussion.
What I do need to say is that
climate change, of course,
is just statistically a reality.
Surface temperatures are
higher in many places,
and even where rainfall
is identical in volume
to what it has
been historically,
the intervals between
one rain to the next rain
are now longer.
The soil is harder
when the rain hits.
It doesn't get absorbed
into the aquifer,
into the underground
storage facilities
that nature gives us.
And therefore, we lose as
much as 90% of the rainfall
now because these
intense rainfalls
come at longer intervals after
the hard pack of the soil.
So climate change
is another factor
is that rain is
not being absorbed.
It's less rain in
much of the world,
and the rain is not being
absorbed in the same way
in much of the world as well.
And then let's talk
about pollution.
We are increasingly and
globally industrialized.
And what does that mean?
It means that in making this
carpet, and making this podium,
and making these chairs,
there's all kinds of chemicals,
and it's all kinds of water
being used in that process.
Now although we have a
very good regulatory regime
here in the United States
with the Clean Water Act,
inevitably, some
types of chemicals
end up finding their
ways into our water.
Whether it's the
discharge from pills
that we all take,
that many of us
take, whether it's from
hairsprays, or creams,
or soaps, or shampoos that
we have that get washed
into our water systems,
our water systems
are increasingly being polluted.
And therefore, water,
large amounts of water,
are being taken offline.
And if this is not as grave a
problem of the United States,
although it is a problem
in the United States,
while it's not as grave of a
problem in the United States,
I want to tell you it
is as grave a problem
as there is in Asia, China,
and India in particular.
We're talking about
billions of people
who have highly tainted water.
And I'll share just two more
macro things to mention.
One is infrastructure.
To a degree that I'm sure
almost nobody here is aware,
we lose incomprehensibly large
amounts of water every day
all over the world,
even here in the US.
So for example, on average,
we lose about 30% of our water
to leaks and infrastructure
failures here in the US-- 30%.
So think about what that means.
Water that we pump,
water that we clean,
water that's ready to go into
your home, into your office,
into your factory, whatever it
is, gets lost along the way.
Now here in California,
18%-- one-eight percent--
of the state electricity bill
goes to the sourcing of water,
the pumping of water,
the cleaning of water,
and the discharge
of water-- 18%.
So 30% of that 18%
is lost, meaning
that lots of carbon fuels
are emitted, lots of water
is wasted needlessly,
lots of expenses incurred,
because we have a
failed infrastructure.
And this is the case
all over the world.
We talk a lot about
our crumbling bridges,
we hear our presidential
candidates talk
about our crumbling bridges,
and our crumbling roads,
and our national infrastructure.
But we hardly ever hear
anyone talking about
are crumbling water
infrastructure.
And that needs to change.
We need to make this a higher
priority of our elected
officials.
And then the final
macro condition
I'd like to mention to
you all is urbanization,
and why is that relevant.
Around the world,
many people are
leaving their small villages
and farms and moving to cities.
And cities are growing outward
larger and larger and larger.
And why is that relevant?
Because what makes up a city?
A city is concrete, and
asphalt, and glass, and metal.
And what is the common
trait of all of those?
Impermeability, water
tightness-- and that's
good for those of us who
are inside on a rainy day.
We don't want to be living
in a tepee when it rains,
and we're getting
wet every which way.
But the bad news
for our water supply
is that then there's
an impermeability also
to the soil below us.
And water gets run off,
and goes to the sea.
So let me take a few minutes
and talk a little bit
about what it is that the
solution is to all of this.
And in each and every
case, the lesson is Israel.
Now I want to hasten to add
two very important things.
First of all, not everything
that Israel has done
is necessarily relevant to
everywhere in the world,
because Israel is
a small country--
I have some maps
here, during the Q&A,
maybe I can show
you some details.
Israel is a small country.
So therefore, just
in terms of scale,
it doesn't do what
needs to be done
in some grand, large places.
And the second
thing I want to say
is that Israelis are not
supermen and superwomen.
What they are is they're
focused on a matter,
they think about a lot,
they care about it a lot,
and they have prioritized
this for a very long time.
And because they
have prioritized it
for a very long time, because
they have dealt with water
scarcity for a very long time,
what this means is that as now
the world is going into a period
with larger population, more
affluent population, more
polluted water, climate
change, less water, less water
flow-- what this means is
that the world now will have
to face a situation very much
like what Israel has been facing
since it first started thinking
about water in the 1930s,
even before it was a state.
Now I'm not going to go into now
the historical reasons and all
that.
We can do this either
in the Q&A and I
have a chapter in the
book that discusses that.
But I will say that most
of what Israel has done
is relevant in at least
one very profound way.
And that is the focus
and the planning.
So what Israel
does is, as I said,
at a very high
level of government,
this is something that
people think about.
In corporate life
in Israel, they
think about water in a way
that we don't yet here.
We will, but not yet.
But until we do
that, until we have
widespread thinking
about this issue,
we're not going to
be in a position
we're going to fix this,
because societies are always
fighting for scarce resources.
Does the money go
to more schools?
Does it go to more military?
Does it go to more bridges?
Does it go to more water?
And we have to influence that.
I think the most significant
thing that Israel
has done, aside
from the technology,
which I'll talk about at
some length in a moment,
is that Israel has radically
transformed agriculture.
When I talk about
this in the book,
I refer to it as
revolutions on the farm.
And I'll talk about
a couple of things
that Israel has
done in particular.
First thing is,
around the world,
where fields are irrigated-- and
the city dwellers don't think
about the farm that
much, but we have
to, because this is
where our water goes.
On average, 70% of the globe's
water goes to agriculture.
That's what it is in the United
States-- 70% of our water
goes to agriculture.
And so we have to think about
what techniques are we using.
Are we smart about our water?
Are we dumb about our water?
And I would argue that
a lot of our water
is really wasted water.
Specifically, the phrase
"flood irrigation," it
goes back to the dawn of time.
It goes back to the Nile River.
And so what was done?
You build channels, you build
canals, you build trenches,
and you divert river water,
or you divert lake water.
Or you, if you have enough
technology to have a pump,
actually, you flood
a whole field.
You peg your seeds down, and
you flood the whole field.
And then some
percentage of the water
finds its way to the roots.
It nourishes the plant, and
then the rest of the water
either dribbles pointless
into the soil, or more likely,
evaporates up into the sky.
And it's lost.
More than half gets lost.
More than 60% of
it's lost, actually.
So Israel invented a system
called drip irrigation.
And what is drip irrigation?
Just as the name implies, as
flood irrigation implies it,
drip irrigation is a system that
places generally subterranean,
below the soil-- but that would
not be a very good photograph.
So I have a photograph
of one that's on land.
You can see these little tubes.
You may have seen them maybe
in somebody's garden here
and there, these little tubes.
And they have very
tiny drippers.
And the drippers drip
at regular intervals
right at the base of the plant.
And as the water is absorbed
into the plant, and just enough
is used to nourish the plant.
Now this is such an
effective device.
And I wasn't planning
on talking about this,
but I just want to throw
it out, since I'm here.
One of the great reasons why we
have so much polluted waterways
in the United States
is because farmers
and the need for ever
greater amount of yield
are planting on ever
more marginal soil.
So what they're doing is they're
using more and more fertilizer,
and more and more nutrients
to add to the plant.
Now why is that a problem?
That's a problem because
when the rains come
at the end of the season,
the leftover fertilizer,
the leftover nutrients
get washed away,
get washed into rivers,
and they remain there.
And that's when you have
these algal blooms that
become terrible problems.
It's the nitrogen,
it's the fertilizer,
that becomes utilized as
feedstock for the algae.
And it blooms, and it
destroys waterways.
It kills off fish, kills off
plant life, and so forth.
But these long devices,
these drip irrigators,
are able to grow plants
in a most remarkable way,
because you can turn
to liquid your nitrogen
and your other fertilizer, and
you can drip very tiny amounts.
You see the soil
here, this is not
high-quality Midwestern soil.
So in Israel, you can actually
grow this in the desert.
And this is a desert picture.
You can see in the
far area the desert.
And you can see in
the near area where
the desert has been reversed
by use of drip irrigation
on sandy soil, like beach soil.
It's not soil, it's just sand.
And what they do is they
have these tiny drippers that
have water and nutrients.
And this is a way to
turn useless areas
into valuable
areas for countries
around the world at a
time when food security is
going to become a problem.
So drip irrigation
is one great solution
to our agricultural problem.
A second solution is
the reuse of sewage.
Israel made a decision
in the early 1950s
that sewage was too valuable
to simply treat and dump.
So let me tell you
what we do here,
what we do right here where
we're sitting right now.
Sewage, in case
you don't know what
it is, is the water
that comes out
of your shower, your bath,
your sink in your kitchen,
your sink in your bathroom, your
washing machine, your dryer,
and, sorry to say, your toilet.
It gets flushed, it gets
flooded out of the house,
it reaches a sewage pipe, it
all comes together in one place.
And under the US
Clean Water Act,
it's treated to an
ultra-high level.
It's fairly
expensive to do this.
It's treated to an
ultra-high level
so that you almost could
drink it if you had to.
Wouldn't want to do a lot of
that, but you almost could.
And then what do we do in the
United States with almost all
of that water?
What do we do with
it right here?
We dump it in the Pacific Ocean.
Why?
It's perfectly
good, usable water.
No one is being asked to put
it into a drinking bottle
and drink it, but
certainly it's good enough
to grow cotton with, or
alfalfa, or other crops.
So in Israel, they made the
decision in the early 1950s
that they were going to
build a parallel plumbing
system, a national
infrastructure
separate from their
clean water system,
separate from their sewage
system, that would take
the water after treatment,
and instead of dumping it
in the Mediterranean, they
would then relocate it
to where farms and fields are.
So think about golf
courses that are sucking up
massive amounts of
fresh, clean water
at a time when we're
running out of water.
Think about the fact of how
many fields there are that suck
water out of aquifers.
And we are running
out of aquifer water
all over the country,
and all over the world,
because we're not
using our sewage
water in an intelligent way.
Now this sounds
like sort of a-- I
don't mean it in a funny way--
it's sort of a dry subject.
But coming to this decision
was a heroic decision.
Feeling comfortable
with transforming
your national agriculture
with drip irrigation
doesn't come easily.
It's a heroic decision.
Heroism, inspiring
stories, are overcoming
what seems like
insurmountable obstacles.
And something that Israel
did, and it's something
that we can do.
We can not only
improve our economy,
we can feel good about ourselves
and have inspiring models
for ourselves as well.
But also, what Israel did
in the world of technology
is that they made a decision to
fulfill an early Zionist dream.
The first prime
minister of Israel
was a man named
David Ben-Gurion.
And he was famous for
expression that we
will make the desert bloom.
Well, this photograph
on the wall
shows that they did
make the desert bloom.
But what's also
true is that they
needed the water to do that.
And Ben-Gurion spoke
repeatedly, speech after speech,
diary entry after diary entry.
And I recount some
of them my book,
of how we came to
think about this.
But he didn't do the work.
Inspiring, heroic
engineers did all this,
people who came up with great
ideas, ideas that were thought
foolish, at first, by many.
I talk about how many
of the people were
rejected by their society,
they were laughed at.
And they plowed ahead.
And so desalination was not
entirely invented in Israel,
but it was largely
invented there.
And we also had lots of
innovations out of Israel.
It's a global phenomenon now,
it's a global industry now.
But much of the greatest
parts are in Israel.
And here I'll show you
Israel's largest of its five
desalination plants.
Now I want to
challenge the audience.
And I was told not to
ask anyone to speak
without a microphone
in front of you,
but I'll repeat the answer.
Can anyone tell me-- I
know Google people are
smart people-- so
who can tell me
what seems to be missing
from this photograph?
This is a desalination plant.
And I'll give you a key phrase
if no one raises their hand
in the next second or two.
What's missing?
Daphne?
Was that Daphne?
Daphne, what did
you say, the sea?
Yeah, it's a seawater
desalination plant
that's about a mile
inland from the sea.
So they built a seawater
desalination plant
where there's no sea around.
Which just goes to show when
there's a will, there's a way.
They thought that the
seashore was too valuable,
and that they didn't
want to use that,
and there was also some
other development in the area
they couldn't break through.
So they built this
desalination plant.
Now this desalination plant
is the world's most efficient
desalination plant.
Despite distance from the ocean,
it produces water more cheaply
than anywhere else in the
world, desalinated water.
It's the healthiest water
you can possibly drink.
It's healthier than water
from a lake or a river.
It's because it's
already been treated,
it basically needs no treatment.
It's pure water.
If you're a pregnant
woman and you're
worried about drinking well
water because of nitrogen
or other things that
can affect your health,
this is the opposite.
This is the best healthy water
as you could possibly drink.
So it's a really a
remarkable thing.
And so today in Israel, if
one could segregate-- now,
this water is merged with
the rest of the fresh water
of the country.
And if one could
merge all together
the water of the
country, it would
be over 85% of the household
water of Israel now
comes from desalinated
sources, which
is a great boost to the
society, and a great boost
for the health of the country.
So where does Israel's
water come from?
There's manufactured water,
and there's natural water.
So think about that.
As we go into a time when we may
be facing severe water scarcity
in a large number
of places, when
we may want to be thinking about
using our water in a completely
different way, it's good to
know that there's a solution.
And the solution is that you
can manufacture your water.
So here in Israel, about 27%
of its manufactured water
comes from the seawater.
About 21% of the water
comes from sewage water
that's treated and then
reused for agriculture.
About 11% of the water
is called brackish water.
That's another
Israeli idea, which
is relevant in some parts of
the world, but not everywhere.
And that is they drill
deep into the desert.
They said to themselves in
the 1950s, if we drill deep
for oil and gas, why can't
we drill deep for water?
And so they drilled deep
into the desert sands.
They found a large mass of
pockets of ancient aquifers
way down in the soil,
enclosed caverns
of brackish water, which
means slightly salty, slightly
mineral-y water.
And they have to desalinate it.
And then they also have
an industry no longer
in active use where
they take stormwater.
Now by the way, as
part of that sewage,
I did mention that they have
a national infrastructure
that they created.
And it takes about at least
10 years to build that.
Israel has over 200
sewage-treated, now clean water
reservoirs where they
store the sewage water.
Because the water-- sewage
is produced every day
in about the same
amount, winter or summer.
But farmers tend to need
water more at one time
of the year than the other.
So you need to have a storage
system all thought out,
all developed, all nationalized.
So in the US, we reuse about 7%
of our water for agriculture.
And in Israel, it's about
85%, 90% of the water
is used for agriculture.
Now what's remarkable is that
if you look at the smaller bar
chart over here, you see
that the aquifers represent
about 28% of the water,
and the Sea of Galilee 10%.
So just imagine that just
a couple of decades ago,
that was all the
water that there was.
And that's all the water that
there is in most of the world.
So is it any surprise that
when, oh, maybe 2/3 of the water
is now coming from artificial
sources or manufactured sources
that we now have scarcity
issues everywhere?
Is any surprise that we're
overdrawing our aquifers?
Is any surprise
that California was
close to running out of
its water in its aquifers
in the San Joaquin Valley,
if it continued at the pace
that it was going
without any regulation?
Far from where we're seated
right now, in the High Plains,
there are eight
US states that are
the breadbasket and the food
basket of the world, that
grows the oats, the
corn, the wheat, sorghum,
other plants that are used
for fodder for animals
and for our breads and
our brains for our cereals
here in the US.
And all over the world,
we all know that there's
a huge, huge industry.
But we don't think about how
it is that that agriculture
industry got created.
In the post World War
II era, the decision
was made to let the US
agricultural industry become
a major exporter.
And so millions of new
acres of land were planted.
But we said before,
agriculture is valuated water.
So they needed the water.
And there is a massive,
continental-sized aquifer,
the Ogallala Aquifer, that lays
beneath these eight states,
from the high in Nebraska, a
little bit to the west in South
Dakota, a touch of Wyoming,
and then straight down
to West Texas, if
you can visualize
that in your mind's eye.
So from 1950 to about
2000, US agriculture
became the world's
savior-- bumper crop year
after year, endless amounts of
exports, billions and billions
of dollars of exports.
But was never
discussed, certainly I
would bet no one
here knows about,
is that the aquifer
underlying all that
has been pumped drier and drier.
About a third of the aquifer got
pumped out in those 50 years.
From 2000 to 2012,
approximately another third
of this massive continental
aquifer was pumped out.
Now here's what I
want you to know.
The shortest guess
is that the Ogallala
Aquifer that I'm talking about
here took 10,000 years to fill.
So in less than a
century, in California,
in the San Joaquin Valley,
in less than a century,
in the Ogallala Aquifer, we
have managed to deplete this.
Now if we stay on
the current course,
the US Geological Survey
now says that by the year
2028-- sounds not that far
away, really-- the Ogallala
Aquifer will be pumped dry.
Then what?
Now, we don't have to
go down that route.
We can be thinking
about water differently.
We can come up with technologies
that don't even exist yet.
The technologies that Israel
has created are wonderful.
uses that they didn't create,
but that they use in full
measure, it's wonderful.
But everything that they're
doing, we can learn from.
And we can be doing
the same, and we
need to be doing the same,
and we must be doing the same.
I started the anecdote
about Theodor Herzl,
and the heroes of the new land
will be the water engineers.
And I told you about Yitzhak
Rabin and his Nobel Prize
speech.
And so I want to just
conclude by saying
that it's a real pleasure,
it's a real honor, frankly,
to been invited here
to speak at Google.
And despite the fact
that it's not exactly
a bus ride to New Jersey to come
from Manhattan to speak here,
the reason I wanted to come is
that probably among the world's
most brilliant
engineers, and the people
who can most affect policy may
well be sitting in this room
right now.
And so I really wanted to
say the reason I wanted
to come here was I
wanted to say to you
all that this is a
problem, this is a crisis,
and this thing that's
not going away.
And so, the extent that we can,
we need to think up solutions.
And we need to make this part
of the national conversation.
I'll pause here.
I'd be glad to answer any
questions that you may have
and-- oh, I'm sorry.
I have one more
slide I want to do.
What some of you
may want to know
is where does that water go.
Similar to what I said
before, is agriculture
is the biggest user of it,
household use, industry,
and so forth.
But I will stop here
and be glad to answer
any questions that anyone
may have about this.
And thank you for
your close attention.
I appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: First of all, thank
you for coming to speak.
That was really,
really informative.
Why does California not
do more desalinization?
Is it because it's
not economical
with the current
policies, versus sort of
free or cheap to
pump groundwater?
Or is it too far from
the San Joaquin Valley?
I'm just curious as to why
the economic drivers haven't
been there.
SETH SIEGEL: Yeah, so the
interest group-- the answer
is that there are
strong interest groups.
And so what ends up happening is
that there's a fight going on,
and has been going for quite
a while, between kind of three
or four interest groups--
the environmental groups,
speaking on behalf of the rivers
and the fish, the farmers,
and the city-dwellers.
And there's also
a legal structure
throughout most of
the US, but certainly
in California, which allows
very long processes that
delay large infrastructure
projects, not just
water, to go forward.
But that is one of them.
And so the cost structure here
has gotten very, very high
because of the delay.
So for example,
down in San Diego,
the same company that built that
inland desalination plant that
I referenced a few minutes ago
has designed a state-of-the-art
one in Carlsbad, California,
right near San Diego.
And it will open in November,
I believe, next month.
Now in Israel, a smaller
plant with more output
took four years to build,
from start to finish.
This Carlsbad plant has been
over 10 years in process.
And many of those years
were spent in litigation.
The cost of an Israeli
desalination plant
is about $400 million, which
is totally amortiz-itable-- I
had it wrong twice now, so
you know what I'm saying.
It could be amortized easily
over the 25-year first life
of the plant.
And then there's a second
life, about 15 years.
I don't have to go into
the economic structure
unless you want me to.
And in California now,
the cost structure
is such that it's going to
be much harder to recoup.
Because it's gone
from $400 million,
which is, in Israel, for
building a comparable plant,
to one now in the US,
that plant costing
about a billion dollars.
So it's a higher cost.
That's first of all.
Second of all is you
have it exactly right.
Politicians do not
like spending money
on invisible infrastructure.
So your question sort of have
had a implication of that.
So politicians, mayors,
governors, city councilmen
and women, they focus very
much on the incentives
that they're given.
And Boris and I,
before we came here,
were talking about why we need a
different governance structure,
because we are in a
different world now.
And we are in a different
world in water as well.
So mayors are in office
four years, or eight years,
or maybe 12 years.
And I told you earlier, it takes
10 to 20 years to build out
a water infrastructure system.
So a mayor has
almost no incentive,
from an electoral
point of view, to be
focusing on what is an expensive
infrastructure, to build it
out.
He has lots of incentive to
build parks, and schools,
and hospitals, or to cut taxes.
And so therefore,
that's what they do.
And until citizens
demand that there
be more water smarts
and more water activity,
it's not going to come.
And finally, in terms of your
question about agriculture,
it would be a bad
idea-- and I didn't
make this clear in
my remarks, and I
should have-- it
would be a bad idea
to be thinking of
desalinating water
for the purpose
of growing crops.
Because there are
still water-rich parts
in the world where it's easier
to grow crops with local water,
natural water, than
using manufactured water.
Manufactured water, as
inexpensive as it has become,
relatively, is
still-- it's a cost.
And therefore, you want
to, if at all possible,
not use desalinated
water for agriculture,
just because of
the cost structure.
Ideally, you use your
desalinated water
as a way of topping
off your system,
and not as a way of
being your system.
Now, we may reach a point,
because of climate change
and the other macro conditions,
where we have no choice.
Just as we agreed to
spend $4 and $5 a gallon
for our gas for
our cars, we make
a decision there's
no other choice,
there may come to that as well.
But I would argue
that the sooner we
get started on thinking
these things through,
the sooner we get
started on building out
our infrastructure,
the sooner we
get started on thinking about
governance and planning,
the smarter that will be.
We do know something.
We do know that there's
going to be another drought.
And then what happens is you
have a couple of rainy days,
you have a rainy season,
and elected officials
who don't want to
spend money, or who
don't want to have
new infrastructure,
or who don't think that we
should build a desalination
plant because it burns
too much carbon fuel,
or because it adds
salty water back
into the ocean-- I have answers
to that as well, within limits.
It's not that big a problem.
They use that as an excuse
to say well, the, aquifers
are refilling, so why
should we do this?
And I think that's an abdication
of very important and necessary
leadership.
AUDIENCE: Could you
comment on the fact
that this, for Israel,
like, it may have been
a strategic way of thinking.
Because obviously, like,
the geography as such
is one that forces
you to-- if you
want to have a viable
economy on this land,
you need to think
about the water issue.
Is that something
that helped sort
of bridge the sort
of bipartisanship
that you might see
in, let's say, the US,
where one group of politicians
may be supporting the people,
and who are holding the water
rights, whereas the other may
be more progressive in trying
to think about these things.
So I guess my question
is how is the support
on both sides of the
political spectrum in Israel
for these kind of projects?
And where does it come from?
And what would be the lessons
for some of the other parts
of the world?
SETH SIEGEL: Thank you.
It's an important question.
And it gives me the
opportunity to actually speak
of one of the several ways that
our governance is broken here
in the United States.
Governance is not just the
elected officials that we have.
Governance is also the way we
choose to conduct and control
how we manage our water.
So we have hundreds
and thousands
of different stakeholders
in water here.
And yet in Israel, what
they made the decision to do
was to build out a system,
and to give one single entity
enormous control.
It's a technocratic,
apolitical body,
and they make the decisions.
And here's the remarkable thing.
I interviewed 220
people for the book.
About-- we didn't
get into it at all.
I didn't talk much
about the effect
that Israel gives water
to the Palestinians.
I wanted to understand
the Palestinian water
claims and the Israeli
issues back and forth.
So I spent a fair amount of
time meeting with Palestinians,
and NGO heads, and such
to understand that issue.
And I'm glad to talk
about it, if anyone
has a question about it.
But what was
interesting was in the,
call it maybe 190
other people that I
spoke to, Israeli people,
business executives, government
officials, stakeholders
in different parts
of the water equation in
Israel, what I was amazed by
was the fact that not
a single one of them
suggested that even though
Israel now has privatized
its economy completely, and even
though Israel now has-- there's
no state-owned bank, there's
no state-owned airline,
there's no state-owned
telecommunications company.
All those have been privatized
in the Margaret Thatcher-style
privatization.
What shocked me was that
not one person I spoke to,
even when I pushed them, not
professors, not economics
professors, not
bankers, no one I
spoke to in the water
equation told me
that they thought it
would be a good idea
to make the free market a larger
part of the water equation.
And so what we have in the
US is that-- I mean, just
to give one example
of California--
if you are along a
river, let's say you're
along the Colorado River, OK?
And you have bad soil,
mostly sandy soil,
and you decide you
want to grow cotton.
Which again, no reason any
of us should know this,
but it's a highly
water-consumptive crop.
And you decide you
want to grow cotton.
And you're right along
the Colorado River.
You can, under
current structure,
take all the water you
want out of the river.
There's no limits whatsoever.
You can flood irrigate your
field to your heart's content.
Now you can't,
then, take the water
and sell it to somebody else.
It's public property
in that regard,
or it's in the flow of property.
But for where you
are along the river,
you take all you want,
as much as you want,
as often as you want.
That would never fly in Israel.
What they made the
decision is that they
need to think about what's
in the best interest,
the highest best use of
a society altogether.
Now I want to just take issue
with one part of your question
now.
And that is the
question about Israel
had necessity in all this.
And I think that was
not necessarily true.
Israel could have
made the decision,
as Singapore did, that it would
have no agriculture at all.
It could have made
the decision that it
would import 100% of its food,
of its fruits and vegetables,
from Europe, or from wherever.
It could have made
that decision.
Now, there's some
national security reasons.
Israel is famously isolated.
And unfortunately,
because of time,
I didn't have a chance to talk
about what I call in the book
hydro-diplomacy, and the ways
in which Israel opened the door
to diplomatic relations
with China and India
through water technology.
Israel understood China and
India's severe water problems,
and used water as a
door-opener, which now they
have robust and
wonderful relations,
but used it as a door-opener
to have relations those two.
But Israel could have
made other choices.
Israel made a decision
to be a country
like all other countries,
to have a great agriculture
sector, to feed
their own people,
not too feed their
cattle-- they feed
their cattle and their
chickens with fodder
that's grown elsewhere.
But all the fruits and
vegetables they eat
are mostly homegrown.
And they made that decision.
And so therefore, they
had to adapt their economy
and their water
plans accordingly.
Now, just imagine if in
the US, first of all,
imagine that we had a water
system, a water governance
system, that wasn't
tied to a time that's
closer to the 19th century, when
there was few people out West,
when there was abundant
water, when no matter how much
water that farmer
upstream would take,
there was still plenty
more for people downstream.
But I didn't finish the story.
What's the problem?
The problem is by the time
that water gets far west,
by the time it gets
to Los Angeles,
by the time it gets even
to Nevada, it's a trickle.
So you have Lake Mead
now at historic low.
You ever seen those
pictures of the Hoover Dam
with those water lines?
If not, if I may say, go
to Google and do a search.
It's really quite remarkable.
And so you find
yourself in a situation
where we have ever less
water, urgently needed,
because we have a
governance system.
Now, I don't think it's a
problem of one political party
or the other.
I think one political
party is more
given to the free market
than the other, I think.
But I think it's frankly that
nobody is paying attention
whatsoever.
It's just off the radar
screen, and that's a problem.
AUDIENCE: So as Boris
mentioned, there
is perhaps, in the
case of Israel,
sort of like a nation-state
interest in developing
this desert.
In the case of making
the analogy to the US,
where its market-driven
forces that really decide what
happens, what is
the alternative?
Where do you see
the future going?
What are going to
be the incentives?
We can't just bury our head
in the sand and say, you know,
it's not a problem.
It will bite us at some point.
SETH SIEGEL: Yeah,
you know, I think--
look, I'm a great believer in,
as I think everyone here is,
in democracies.
So the problem that democracies
are that crucial decisions get
pushed off for a very long
time, until they become crises.
So the premise of your question
implies a smart governance
system where we
move more rapidly.
And I'm not as
optimistic as you are.
I see, again and
again in our history,
where we do ultimately address
problems and address them well,
but we address them late.
And so therefore,
terrible problems
develop before we get there.
But I'll tell you what
I would like to see,
I don't know that I will see.
First of all, I'd like
to just see immediately,
lots more technology at work.
I'd like to see a different
tax policy so that we
have incentives for
farmers so that they
will adopt technology.
I mean, think about this.
If water is a free
input, why would you
spend one penny for
technology to save water?
It makes no sense.
And I have a story that
is an East Coast story,
but people always can't quite
believe it, but it's true.
In 1980, in-- well
let me step back.
New York City gets
its water from a bunch
of-- from the greater watershed.
It's very healthy, good water.
And it comes from these enormous
water pipes that are probably
about the size, or maybe half
the size of this large room
that we're in right now.
You could drive a truck
through it, it's so large.
And these are
massive water pipes.
There are two of them
that feed New York.
And in 1980, they discovered
in one of the pipes
that there was a leak, a
leak in one of the pipes.
And it wasn't just any leak.
It was an unusually large leak.
The leak was leaking 35 million
gallons every single day.
It's a lot of water.
So if you were leaking
35 million gallons a day,
and there was a cost to
that water of $1 a gallon
or a penny a gallon or
tenth of a penny a gallon,
what you would probably
do is you'd probably
pretty quickly do a
cost-benefit analysis and say,
got to fix the damn leak.
But instead, the
decision was made,
they knew it was a problem.
They knew sooner or later
they'd have to fix it.
But the attitude was
infrastructure is expensive,
and water is free.
So if water is free, why fix it?
And so now we are
1980, 2000, 2010-- so
now we are 34
years later, is it?
We're 34, 35 years later-- 35,
2015-- we're 35 years later.
And here I'm going to
tell you where we are.
35 million gallons a day,
that's a lot of water.
Last year, they made
the decision to fix it.
They have a seven-year
project to fix it.
It's going to cost
about a billion dollars.
So 41 years after they
discovered a leak,
leaking 35 million gallons
a day, it will be fixed.
Now, that is a big story.
Bring that down to
microcosm to a farmer.
As long as water is free, or
functionally free, or highly
subsidized, as
long as it's highly
subsidized for
homeowners, we're going
to keep doing silly,
reckless things.
So one of things that Israel
does, I didn't get a chance
to talk about
before, is it charges
a real price for the water.
But every penny that's
charged goes to a lockbox.
It's used only for water
infrastructure and water
management.
What happens in America is
the same mayors I talked about
before, they have water
fees, they have sewage fees,
it goes into the general pot, it
goes into the general treasury,
and they don't use
it to fix the water.
And so therefore, they're happy
to be sloppy with their water.
And that's something
that we can't afford.
Maybe we could afford
it once upon a time,
I'm arguing that we cannot
afford it going forward.
So when do we fix it?
We fix governance, we
fix our infrastructure,
we fix our financing
system, we perhaps
have some eminent domain, when
we say somebody's use of water
is inappropriate
for the rest of us.
And we have to start thinking
about this differently.
And we have to have our
federal government rethink
the way it manages water.
Because the management
of water is back
in a time when there were
different society completely,
not scarcity issues
looming, and not
the problems that we have today.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank you so much.
So I want to ask about one thing
you didn't mention much about
was the terms stormwater
and greywater.
And I was wondering, do you
think it's practical for us
to actually separate
out-- I mean,
like, there are many types
of sewage, in a sense,
and in a lot of places,
stormwater and sewage
is all just the same, and all
goes to the same treatment
plant, and then you end up with
sewage overflowing when there's
too much rain, and so forth.
Is it practical to
actually develop
sort of separate systems for
stormwater, for greywater,
for black water?
I mean, greywater and
stormwater are easier to treat
and more reusable.
Do you think that's
a practical thing
to do in the United States?
SETH SIEGEL: The answer is
yes, I think it's doable.
I think it's a question
of prioritization.
And you have to make a
decision as to where you want
to spend your water dollars.
I think that probably, there
are possibly better dollars
to be spent first.
But I think this is one
of these moments where you
have to consider all options.
And regionally
speaking, in some places
where you have lots of rain
that gets lost to the sea,
is a good place to be
thinking about this.
I think storm capture
water is a fabulous idea.
I agree with you that it's--
it's not as easy to treat
as you may think, by the way.
Stormwater raindrops, when
they fall from the sky,
they're pretty pure.
But the second
they hit the soil,
they pick up what's left from
the car, and truck, and bus
exhaust, and they pick up lots
of silt, and lots of sand.
And so by the time they get
into the treatment center,
it's pretty dirty.
It's filled with chemicals,
and it's pretty dirty stuff.
But it's a good idea to have
that as part of the mix,
particularly in
parts of the country
where you have a significant
amount of seasonal rain.
So you can trap that rain.
You can treat that rain.
And then you can put
it in large reservoirs
where it can be useful later.
And by the way, Israel does
something just like that,
but they haven't been
doing that as much
lately, because they made the
decision that it's actually
more cost effective
to take water
from sewage, because
there's a lot of it,
and treat that and reuse that.
But they have, as
you saw in my chart,
they have a little
bit of stormwater
recapture that they use now.
But I think it may make more
sense for parts of the United
States that have seasonally
high amounts of water, though.
AUDIENCE: That's helpful.
SETH SIEGEL: One last
word I'd like to say
is that the Middle East is a
famous region for conflict.
And most of what we see about
Israel in the Middle East,
unfortunately, we
don't get a chance
to see enough inspiring
stories out of the Middle East.
And there are many
of those as well.
This book, and I know
Google, very kindly,
is providing copies
for everybody here.
And thank you to
Google for that.
The book is actually, I
think, full of inspiring
stories of people overcoming
insurmountable obstacles.
And I think that this is one
such story that is one that's
good for all of us to hear.
And I hope that
this is something
that people understand it's
not just sort of an engineering
story, but a story that is
applicable to all of our lives,
and large challenges that we
face in society generally,
which is sort of
way Boris kindly
started this whole conversation.
So I think that we're probably
at the end of our hour.
And I thank you
all very, very much
for your time and attention.
If anybody wants to
linger after we finish,
I'd be glad to standby and
speak with those of you
who are shy, if any of you are.
BORIS: Thank you.
Please join me in thanking
Seth for coming to visit.
[APPLAUSE]